hallo freunde wir müssen reden in der
vario folge von heute mittag bzw heute
morgen ist das hier vorne passiert was
ich euch hier längst mal eben ein
blender scheinlich kommt jetzt alles
dazu auch noch genau jetzt so manegold
leiter so ein scheiß daher gut hatte
schon gesehen ich habe meinen texture
pack gewechselt ich hab damit die ersten
45 minuten mit 6 gespielt und nicht mit
dem was im regelwerk vorgeschrieben war
mit dem facebook schipek deswegen ist
das ganze halt einen strike jetzt
wahrscheinlich in der zweiten folge
schon im titel gesehen und auf dem
fremden ale dass ich da schon gezeigt
habe ja das ist ein streik weil ich im
video und im schnitt echt überhaupt
nicht richtig bemerkt habe allerdings
ist es mir dann halt nachher beim
hochladen und dann nochmal anschauen
aufgefallen und ich dann natürlich
direkt in die skype conti von wago drei
reingeschrieben halo was machen wir
jetzt noch ein strike und so weiter und
so fort viele haben auf freispruch
plädiert und ja hier das ist doch nicht
so schlimm luca du als männer bekommen
nicht mal jeder der meine minecraft
skills wie team einen kanal und die
minecraft pvp videos darauf kennt weiß
dass ich das überhaupt nicht gemacht
habe um irgendeinen vorteil zu
erschließen lässt sondern das ganze ein
versehen aber ich kann natürlich
nachvollziehen dass darauf entschieden
wurde das ist halt ein streik war es
waren regelverstoß ich hab mich nicht
regelkonform verhalten und deswegen habe
ich nun einen strike ich wollte durch
hier nochmal kurz erklären und zwar sind
wir so verblieben dass heute als er die
folge gesehen habt um 12 uhr wurden
meine koordinaten veröffentlicht bei uns
in der skype konnte ich für alle noch
verfügbaren war teilnehmer da der server
dementsprechend heute auch um 16 uhr
online gegangen ist bin ich natürlich
direkt um 16 uhr freund und habe alles
versucht um irgendwie zu überleben
allerdings seht ihr das alles am
dienstag in part 4 bei mir ist auch
komplett egal ihr werdet halt dienstag
im part 4 auf meinem kanal und auch
eventuell auf ein paar anderen kanälen
sehen wie diese jagd ausgesehen hat ob
er überhaupt leute nach geträumt und ob
ich der einzige auf dem server war oder
ob alle anderen teams nachgebaut sondern
mich gesucht haben weil meine
koordinaten ja öffentlich waren ich
wollte mit diesem video nur noch mal
ganz kurz sagen ja ich weiß dass ich ein
regelverstoß begangen habe ich weiß dass
ich das ist ein streik war
und es tut mir leid weil unter der folge
heute mittag hatten einige geschrieben
du hast deinen text ausgewählt das ist
doch ein strike oder das wollte ich nur
mal ganz gut festhalten ich habe es
gesehen wir haben schon in der gruppe
dadurch entschlüsse getroffen und seine
koordinaten von schon gepostet die folge
schon aufgenommen von heute mittag
beziehungsweise heute um 16 häufig die
folge aufgenommen ob ich die folge
überlegt ob mir und nicht leute getötet
haben ob ich geschafft habe
forever seht ihr am dienstag in papier
von ware und sonst will ich sagen war es
auch schon mit diesem ganz kurzen video